as our valley continues to grow more
projects are in the works including one
near nellis and las vegas boulevard the
area set to be developed used to be a
walmart and tonight many who live nearby
are indicating what they'd like to see
there next 8 news now's sally jaramillo
is live in the northeast part of the
valley with more on these upcoming
changes sally
kirsten you might recall the building
behind me it is an old walmart well it
has been vacant for more than four years
and today many people who live in the
area say they would like it to come back
to life or at least try to get another
grocery store nearby
in front of the old walmart on craig and
nellis right across from where i live
right now
the cliffs at dover adrian donnell has
lived in the area for three and a half
years she says her community is a brand
new town home that was completed with
over 500 owners i was always hopeful
that we would get a walmart or a target
or some sort of a grocery store because
we live in a food poverty area a food
desert donnell says currently the
closest store is four to five miles away
so we desperately need a store that
might be in walking distance for people
who don't drive our community is mostly
retired people just recently it came to
her attention that this particular area
where the walmart used to be located
will soon become an industrial area
something they don't want as they say it
will leave the door open for a future
manufacturing company to move in
increasing truck traffic on craig the
only thing they wanted was a
manufacturing zoning and our needs were
not being considered and that's the
reason why the petition was started it's
important because
we want a grocery store carl david
eckert has been in the area for five
years and agrees i'm a handicapped
individual for me to go to the store i
have to take my scooter
and run up the street crossing my
fingers and gets across something close
to heart as he was born in las vegas and
says what he's seeing out here is not
developing as it should anything that
would take care of the customers not a
convenience store we can't go get fresh
vegetables at the gas station
back out live we did reach out to the
developer and are still waiting to hear
back we also reached out to the county
and in a statement they say commissioner
marilyn kirkpatrick said we expect the
new grocery store will open near craig
and ellis by july and we are planning to
host farmers markets in that area soon
too meanwhile we are working to bring
additional new businesses to the area to
provide more job opportunities for
residents unquote and if you would like
to participate in that petition as well
we have posted all of that information
and much more on our website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live
sally jaramillo live local now